it's been 36 hours and globo's taking a  problem unless if someone out like you  know went here and cut off the police  finder where be anti spell for any news  it is only five years oh please please  help - in relation to the specific  investigation as I said earlier were  pursuing a number of lines of inquiry  unmarked bridges one of them on in  relation to the images that I circulated  to you earlier today which was the Land  Rover Discovery map which is  photographed and I again ask did you see  this vehicle between Monday evening and  Tuesday afternoon do you know mark Roger  and did you see him - the knapsack  period Monday evening and Tuesday  afternoon and if you have any  information please contact us on the  child rescue alert line 0 300 mm 3 3 3  do not assume somebody else has already  contacted us with information even if  you feel yours is trivial it may be the  vital piece that we are missing